l'arrestation a eu lieu aux petites
heures du matin en floride
les taux vient de se resserrer autour de
wayne johnston menottes au poignet
l'homme de 66 ans a été inculpé de sept
chefs d'accusation dont ceux de fausses
déclarations de subornation de témoin et
d'obstruction à une procédure officielle
semblant fier de lui même
ouah johnston est ensuite sorti de la
course brandissant le v de la victoire
tout comme son idole l'ancien président
richard nixon auquel il a toujours voué
un culte total jeu plaiderait non
coupable et je gagnerai en cours at il
déclaré stone a ensuite été remise en
liberté conditionnelle contre le
versement d'une caution de 250 mille
dollars
cela fait plus d'un an et demi que le
procureur spécial rock ne leur tente de
déterminer s'il ya eu collusion ou
coordination entre l'équipe de campagne
de donald trump et la russie en 2016
selon les enquêteurs stone savez entre
autres que l'organisation de julian
assange wikileaks vu par certains comme
étant pro kremlin allait publier les
courriels piratés dans le camp démocrate
susceptible de nuire à la campagne
présidentielle de ville abrite l'antenne
est la sixième personne arrêtée dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur la collusion
avec la russie les cinq autres dont
michael flynn et pullman à ford ont déjà
plaidé coupable pour certains de leurs
crimes
rogers stone qui s'est décrit un jour
comme un habitué des coups fourrés est
un ami et conseiller informel de donald
trump
depuis des décennies mais ces
accusations du sahara centers n'ont rien
à voir avec le président ni avec la
maison blanche
trump en a rajouté sur son réseau social
préféré en parlant encore une fois de la
plus grande chasse aux sorcières de
l'histoire alors que selon lui il n'y a
pas de collusion
n'empêche l'anc est sûre cette collusion
se poursuit et d'autres arrestations
sont à prévoir
si frédéric arnould radio canada
montréal